bonjour à toutes et à tous pour vous
parler aujourd'hui déblocage du
développement nous allons nous baser sur
le manuel de géographie 3e 6e des
éditions de bouc
la question que nous nous posons c'est
comment expliquer les disparités de
développement alors que ce soit à
différentes échelles
ça peut être à une échelle mondiale
entre les pays du nord et les pays du
sud ou à une échelle régionale entre les
régions d'un état comme nous le voyons
actuellement avec la chine
tout d'abord ce que l'on peut dire au
niveau des disparités développement ce
soit à l'échelle mondiale et celle d'un
pays c'est qu'il existe véritablement un
cercle vicieux de la pauvreté
tout d'abord un pays pauvre une région
pauvre à une économie qui ne permet pas
d'arriver aux standards classiques du
développement alain faible niveau de
revenu régional ou national
ce faible niveau de revenu va avoir des
conséquences
la première c'est une demande qui va
être limité cette demande limitée
évidemment les gens et ont peu d'argent
à dépenser
ils vont peut solliciter les entreprises
et les entrepreneurs locaux
on aura une faible incitation à investir
dans ces régions là les intérêts les
entrepreneurs et les investisseurs ne
voient pas comment rentable ce
territoire là les investissements sont
donc faibles
ces investissements faible produit une
productivité faible qui elle même va
engendrer un faible niveau de revenu
national
la boucle est bouclée évidemment le
système fonctionne avec d'autres
réservoirs à d'autres circuits puisque
le faible niveau de revenu empêche un
niveau d'épargné important puisque
l'essentiel des revenus des personnes
vivent sur ce territoire est investi
pour assurer les besoins du taux de base
ne permettra donc de dégager une épargne
sans capacité d'épargné bien c'est une
incapacité à investir et on en revient
justement à ces investissements faibles
d'un autre côté le fait que la
population souffre d'un faible revenu va
la conduire à des niveaux de
malnutrition ou en tout cas des niveaux
de précarité physiques et moraux haut
niveau la précarité physique et bien
évidemment ça va engendrer une
productivité assez faible puisque les
organismes seront évidemment fatigué ou
épuisés par ce cas heureusement donc
vous voyez que d'une manière ou d'une
autre on arrive toujours d'une façon
systémique donc en boucle ont à chaque
fois la boucle à avoir un renforcement
de cette pauvreté ou en tout cas de ce
mal développement les deux grandes
théories du développement nous avons vu
en classe au premier semestre à savoir
la théorie de la dépendance la théorie
du water vont permettre de comprendre ce
mal développement
en ce qui concerne la théorie de la
dépendance on peut sortir d'un d'une
approche purement spatiale comme nous
l'avons vu avec le modèle centre
périphérie pour nous intéresser à une
dimension beaucoup plus social les
situations du sous développement
économique sont alors le fruit de
domination sociale culturelle politique
et économique
voici quelques exemples de ces
situations qui peuvent plonger un peuple
dans la stagnation économique et même la
misère on va voir les castes où les
oligarchies qui peuvent maintenir dans
des situations misérable une grande
partie de la population en usant de
leurs privilèges de leurs forces pour
rester au pouvoir est confisqué et bien
sûr toutes les ressources et tout le
pouvoir à l'ensemble de la population
les dictatures aussi soumettent la
population par la peur ou la terreur
alors certains régimes pratique les
disparitions les enlèvements les
meurtres voir des viols et annihile
toute envie de changement politique
économique ou social
les conditions de la femme parfois liés
à l'intégrisme religieux peuvent
entretenir les situations sociales
dramatiques et empêché tout
développement
quand on sait que la femme joue un rôle
essentiel dans le développement
d'utiliser un régime d'apartheid ne
permet pas à tous les habitants d'un
territoire d'avoir accès au même niveau
de développement économique economic
éducationnel culturel et social
la répartition inéquitable des ter entre
les habitants peut également provoquer
un blocage du développement et il n'est
pas rare de constater que 5% de la
population détient plus de 80% des
terrains un pays
si les aviculteurs ne parviennent pas à
acheter une parcelle ils n'investissent
pas alors dans leurs exploitations
agricoles et on a une aberration
économique qui peuvent souscrire
plusieurs hypothèses bien sûr sont
avancées pour expliquer ces domination
est la principale c'est l'héritage de la
colonisation le sous-développement
économique et résulte de l'exploitation
du thème du tiers monde par les pays
industrialisés
à ce stade on ne peut pas faire
l'économie d'une approche géographique
pour comprendre les blocages du
développement au nord les territoires
des pays sont structurées par exemple
les aviateurs se fournissent auprès des
industries pour obtenir leur matériel et
leurs produits ils obtiennent des
crédits auprès des banques
les productions agricoles sont
transformés dans des industries
aboutissent dans les supermarchés débile
ce territoire et d'y articulé puisqu'il
existe des liens entre les différentes
parties de ce territoire et entre les
acteurs de celui ci au sud le territoire
et des structures et les acteurs de ce
territoire
les paysans les grandes entreprises et
les petits métiers de zones urbaines
entretiennent peu de lien entre eux il
existe donc une désarticulation
économique qui ne va pas vers une
efficacité du modèle économique viable
on va analyser successivement le secteur
rural traditionnel le secteur des
grandes firmes multinationales et les
villes et on va voir la déstructuration
de tout ce territoire et le peu de liens
qui lient entre ces différents éléments
le secteur rural traditionnel constitue
généralement une partie du territoire
souvent mal desservies par les moyens de
transport oncle avait peu fertile est
consacrée aux petites exploitations
familiales
l'économie est souvent basée sur l'auto
consommation des productions vivrières
le maïs le riz le mil et et c'est un
léger surplus quand ils existent et
destinés au marché local ces paysans
très n'entretiennent plus de relations
économiques et sociales avec le reste du
pays exception faite de l'exode rural
quand ils décident de quitter leur
région pour rejoindre les villes autres
parties du territoire a consacré aux
grandes exploitations agricoles ou
grandes entreprises extractives soif de
minerais voire de pétrole
les activités économiques sont basés sur
l'exportation des produits agricoles
comme la canne à sucre la banane le café
du coton et des matières premières
routes des voies ferrées relié au port
structurent le territoire la production
est cette fois tournés vers le marché
mondial les liens avec le secteur
traditionnel se résume souvent à des
emplois temporaires pour les paysans
peut s'empêcher ici de penser au cas du
niger qui est très qui contient qui est
un sous sol très riche en minerais
d'uranium totalement exploité par areva
géant français du nucléaire ce qui est
un paradoxe quand on sait que les
nigériens n'ont quasi pas accès à
l'électricité
cette opposition vraiment entre deux
types de population avec des objectifs
totalement différent on la retrouve dans
les villes les quartiers modernes
industriels des affaires de la finance
ou du tourisme sont tournés vers
l'extérieur du pays avec l'importation
un tourisme important des modes de vie
proche de nouveau et l'occident tout à
côté de cela des bidonvilles existe
l'économie informelle apparaît pour
répondre aux besoins de cette population
exclue et rejetée ainsi l'organisation
des territoires du pays 10 ultra vu
souvent des situations de blocage et de
dépendance économique entre les
campagnes et la ville les relations sont
faibles la campagne ne fournit pas les
céréales aux citadins les céréales sont
apportées pour lui et les industries ne
produisent pas toujours pour le marché
local mais bien pour le marché
international
cette schématisation permet de
synthétiser
cette disparité ces disparités
territoriales et cette problématique
d'un territoire désarticulé on va voir
que dans les territoires les zones les
plus ingrates tant au niveau climatique
au niveau du relief ce sont généralement
les populations de souche les petites
exploitations agricoles familiales qui
vont vivre et subsister en ne produisant
que de petites quantités vous et une
économie d'autosubsistance à côté cela
les territoires les plus favorables vont
être exploitées par des multinationales
ou de grosses structures en vue
d'exporter l'ensemble de la production
setek ses exportations sont permises par
des villes portuaires véritable porte
d'entrée et de sortie du territoire par
rapport à l'international et le reste du
monde
dans ces villes portuaires nous
retrouverons bien sûr des quartiers
d'affaires les quartiers résidentiels où
les populations qui se sont enrichis
grâce au commerce international vous
résidez elles sont directement connectés
bien sûr aux zones franches ou des
multinationales et des investisseurs
étrangers sont venus à la recherche de
rendements juteux et à côté de ça on a
une périphérie au sein de ces villes
délaissés ou des bidonvilles et les
favelas sont voués à une économie de
subsistance
généralement les populations de ces
quartiers sont issues de l'exode rural
et en venant en ville n'ont
malheureusement pas réussi à trouver
l'eldorado qui était espéré
bien sûr les quartiers riches et les
zones franches ont peu de contacts avec
les agriculteurs issus du modèle
traditionnel qui laisse évidemment ceci
dans
j'ai un état de mal développement quasi
sans perspective d'avenir
cette vidéo est maintenant terminée
alors n'oubliez pas la prise de notes
qui est essentiel verba volant scripta
manent et les paroles s'envolent les
écrits restent
si vous avez des questions nos télés
également pourront vous être utile aux
cours pour les poser pour changer avec
un camarade avec le professeur et ne
partez pas sans répondre aux questions
et bien d'autres